so when is it appropriate to like cut
communication off with someone like when
would you say so I think this is a
goal-oriented question and there's a
reason why multiple times here I made it
a point that this is not based on some
objective list of do's and dont's
without a point of reference because
it's easy to miss here some of this
stuff as as saying oh just be a harmless
little nice person who never makes
anyone uncomfortable and I don't believe
that at all no I believe there's a time
in a place to to disregard how
comfortable other people are with your
truth okay
I believe there's the time in a place
but I but I believe this is a
goal-oriented matter if you want a
relationship with someone right then you
have to ask yourself what are the costs
what are the costs that are involved
with me creating that result and am I
willing to pay that pay those costs
because what does that relationship look
like yeah because the relationship isn't
a nebulous thing where you're like I
want this person my life even though
it's it's awful what you're saying is
what is that ideal not perfect but ideal
relationship look like and then what are
the cost of that ideal relationship yeah
and I can guarantee you for all the
relationships that were in we put up
with inconveniences because we believe
they're worth the cost and you better
believe there's some outsider looking at
us do that and thinking to themselves
hah I never put up with that right and
that's okay that's okay for them right
but we've made up our minds for the
further relationships that we have with
our customers or our significant others
or our friends that based on my goals
based on my values this is something I'm
willing to deal with when I worked at an
assisted living facility I worked with
older people who had dementia people in
their 80s and 90s
and sometimes these people not being in
their right mind would say some really
cruel things I mean sometimes I you know
me at me and this other black guy used
to work there together with only two two
brothers there and we used to joke
around sometimes like man I think they
think that we're living back in the day
and in the time before time the way
they're talking to us right but but but
I didn't respond to them in the way that
I might respond to a man on the street
right because I factual because it was
contextual man it was contextual and I
was willing to put up with something
coming from them because of the loved
for them because of the understanding I
had of where they were because of the
empathy and so forth
you